there it is so russell wilson you know
like me
i didn't have a steve young jersey but
grew up a steve young fan and now
he has joined steve young as the only
players in nfl history
with thirty thousand passing yards and
four thousand rushing yards and you
wanna talk about bookmarks things we
didn't
get to yesterday you know russell wilson
against the falcons in the opener had
four incompletions
and four touchdown passes and this is
russell wilson appreciation day because
because if you think about it first of
all we know he should have two super
bowls we know
and we know why i should have two super
bowls so we don't have to rehash that
okay
i don't know i don't know well okay all
right i don't know
i'll be sidetracked i won't get
soundtrack all right go ahead go ahead
go anywhere
but i but we're talking about a guy
whose career
he started off with being too short and
then his defense was a star in seattle
if not his head coach there were the
unfortunate conversations
about his blackness or lack thereof
for a period there in seattle that he
was a lightning rod in his own locker
room
people argue there was his beautiful
wife and sierra
and a lot of observation and
appreciation about that but i don't know
that russell wilson
you know how much of a trigger word and
how much of a pet peeve
underrated is for me michael i hate that
word
because it's thrown around way too
liberally but in this
game if you if russell wilson has never
gotten so much as an
mbp vote that count that constitutes
under appreciated and underrated for a
guy who not only is a first ballot hall
of famer
who is putting together the kind of
career that makes him one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time
right now i love i love watching him
play i think he is underrated
i know i know we use that i i even use
that term too much but in this case it's
accurate
why because i don't think anybody is
going to look at
a 511 quarterback with the production of
russell wilson like russell wilson was
in college
at wisconsin and north carolina state
you know whatever
i don't think anybody's going to say
well he's 511 he's too short
he's productive he's smart he can run
our offense but he just doesn't have the
size so we're going to wait until the
third round to draft him
i don't think that's going to happen of
fact i noticed not gonna happen as colin
murray
hey number one overall pick yeah that's
what five eight
so maybe that that that alone
that alone that russell wilson you know
breaking some of the antiquated uh
patterns of nfl general managers and you
laid it out perfectly
there were so many excuses so many
reasons to hide
russell wilson's talent so many reasons
to ignore it whether it's the legion of
boom whether it's
pete carroll marshawn lynch a lot of big
personalities out there in the pacific
northwest
a lot of winning too and there are a lot
of a lot of reasons you could say oh
this is why the team is successful but
clearly
thirty thousand passing yards and four
thousand rushing yards that doesn't
happen by accident
he is a great quarterback and i don't
understand why he hasn't had
uh any kind of mvp votes or hasn't been
in the mvp conversation seriously
that's incredible well he's been in the
conversation but the votes is different
i just want to well but but yes
you're not in the game hey listen if
you're not going to get any votes you're
not in the conversation don't put me in
a conversation unless you're willing to
spend some capital and vote and vote for
michael
so listen you know every now and then
i'm not a numbers guy but i do like them
all right so but so every now and then i
just they blow your mind right
do you i think you probably know who the
highest rated quarterback in nfl history
is
right you have to take a guess who do
you think is the highest rated
quarterback in the first round he's
active
we didn't talk about him he threw i
think four touchdowns on sunday
you know as his as his heir apparent
watching the sideline
drew brees no aaron rodgers
is that rogers i didn't know yeah no i
was i gave you so many hands i was like
he threw four touchdowns his airplane
was on the sideline that's okay
my point is bring it up there roger
i was like reporting bringing up aaron
rodgers all right
james winston no but my point in
bringing up aaron rodgers
is the second highest rated quarterback
nfl history you put stock in it is
russell
wilson by literally one point below
aaron rodgers russell wilson
the second highest rated quarterback in
history i saw say he's one of the best
of all time i'm not kidding it's not
hyperbole
and and you know here's the other thing
i i want you to uh i just thought of
this
russell wilson who's the uh
who's the best wide receiver you think
that he has thrown to
in his career that's why i've received
him
i mean i know you know doug yeah doug
baldwin had had a big season for him
uh yeah he had percy harvin for a while
that didn't really work out for them
the way they they thought it would i
mean think about it think about it
for a second yeah golden tate was a good
receiver for them
so yeah and i and this this leads us to
another conversation for another this is
truly another day down the road where
i think i think quarterbacks make
receivers much more often than receivers
make quarterbacks
but uh he hasn't been he hasn't been
he hasn't been blessed with what you
would call
these top five top 10 wide receivers
or offensive line for that matter i mean
he's been running for his life
is pretty much his whole career you know
in seattle again he's had a great
defense
but as dr jason johnson talked about
earlier like they letting him cook so
it's like one of the things i was most
excited about week one we spent a lot of
time rightfully so
on cam newton and his apparent
resurgence and rebirth
in new england i mean if this is a
sample of what we're going to get from
russell wilson
this season at minimum he's going to get
some votes for mvp
and maybe this is one of those lifetime
achievement mvps like this is long
overdue
maybe this is his denzel and training
day moment it may he may or may not put
together his best season
but he gonna get recognized for all the
seasons you know that he has not gotten
some mvp love i mean i think you know
you can count on you can literally count
on one hand the amount of interceptions
that he's thrown each of the last two
seasons
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports